the bigger they are the harder they fall
celebrity is a tough business all-around
and the pressures of Fame and wealth can
be too much for some actors to handle
while these are problems that most
people would envy these actors might beg
to differ they came close to Dee railing
their careers but we're glad they were
able to rebound back into the spotlight
Natalie Portman Natalie Portman has
never really left the public eye but she
sees it differently
she told New York Magazine I was in the
biggest grossing movie of the decade and
no director wanted to work with me which
makes it sound like most of Hollywood
agreed with a hate that hardcore fans
have for the Star Wars prequels I come
to the wolf
good job Binks yo - yes I need your help
but with the help of some friends in
high places she bounced back a series of
rolls of movies like cold mountain
Garden State closer and Black Swan now
Portman is once again considered one of
Hollywood's top actresses she appeared
in the first two Thor movies and her
role in ex machina director Alex
Garland's and I elation suggests she
still knows how to pick a script Paul
Reubens you probably know him as pee-wee
Herman and the scandal that derailed his
career has been a punchline for years in
1991 Paul Reubens was arrested for
indecent exposure inside an adult
theater because apparently most watched
adult films for the thrilling plots in
the fallout from the incident CBS
stopped airing reruns of pee-wee's
Playhouse and Reubens retreated from the
public eye for many years after years
out of the limelight Reubens reclaimed
his famous character donning the gray
suit and red bowtie once again for the
2016 Netflix film pee-wee's big holiday
nearly 30 years after the characters
last major film big top peewee the new
release was positively embraced by fans
and critics alike Robert Downey jr. he
had promising beginnings in a number of
critically acclaimed big-budget films
not to mention a stint on SNL but Robert
Downey jr. sudden fame mixed with an
undiagnosed bipolar disorder resulted in
a number of drug and alcohol-related
arrests in the late 90s after cleaning
up Zach Downey started to roll out the
hits appearing in Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
Gothika Iskander darkly and Tropic
Thunder he's most known for his ongoing
lead roles in Guy Ritchie's Sherlock
Holmes series
and in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
Tony Stark also known as Iron Man
nothing like staring at a multi-billion
dollar franchise to pull you out of a
little personal slump ah Mike Tyson the
terrifying Tyson didn't start his career
as an actor but found a renaissance is
one know best is a boxing champion
Tyson's controversial life has included
multiple accusations of violence against
women longtime drug and alcohol abuse
but I knew when I was in that quote and
while we get that road under the roof
we'll be good biting off a chunk of
Evander Holyfield's ear in their 1997
rematch after retreating from the public
eye in shame Tyson found a new life by
appearing in the hangover from 2009
since then he got his own cartoon series
Mike Tyson mysteries Holyfield and Tyson
appeared together in a post-credits
scene during the 2013 boxing movie
grudge match you can also catch Tyson
taking on martial arts in action start
Donnie Yen in it man 3 drew Barrymore
child actors drew Barrymore his career
was almost over before it began after
starring in the 1982 hit et at age 7
Barrymore became notorious for abusing
alcohol marijuana and cocaine by her own
admission starting at the age of 8
fortunately thanks to rehab and the
unlikely help of a family friend had to
live with David Crosby 41 which is crazy
because David had his own problem I know
he is he was an interesting character
and itself Barrymore found sobriety and
started her wildly successful second act
starring movies like scream the wedding
singer and never been kissed
Barrymore also focuses on her family and
charity work while appearing in ads is
one of the faces of covergirl but that
doesn't mean she's slowing down in terms
of acting despite the fact that she only
took four roles from 2009 to 2016
because if she could come back from
being a teenage addict and the train
wreck that was Charlie's Angels full
throttle she can come back from anything
Fred Willard comedian and actor Fred
Willard's career was marked by nothing
but funny movies until his 2012 arrest
for a lewd act in an adult theater the
arrests cost him his job hosting market
warriors but will it was quick to
recover after an honest interview on
Late Night with Jimmy Fallon in which he
showcased his legendary sense of humor
Jimmy what do you want to talk about
first
you know let me say this it's the last
time I'm gonna listen to my wife when
Jesus why don't you go out to see a
movie yes since then he's appeared in
anchorman 2 the legend continues 50
shades of black and a handful of
television roles and most likely
discovered the joys of private browsing
mode Mickey Rourke
former boxer and semi reluctant actor
Mickey Rourke enjoyed a successful
career until he was arrested for spousal
abuse in 1994 after assaulting his then
wife Carrie Otis oh yeah
Annie was responsible for getting her
accidentally shot in the chest once -
just a guess but he probably didn't get
a world's best husband bug that
Christmas as a result Rourke almost gave
up the spotlight completely returning to
boxing then to acting than the boxing
again wait is he boxing in a kilt
anyway he bounced back to acting for
good with a lead role in 2005 Sin City
let's go this major return which he
attributes to his manager and his dogs
led to Rourke appearing in The Wrestler
Iron Man 2 and the Expendables Rob Lowe
in the age of the Kardashians it's hard
to remember that a sex tape could once
ruin someone's career and Rob Lowe had
one of the first only a few years into
his career Lowe was filmed with at least
three different women one of whom was
barely above legal age sparking a wave
of media controversy when the tape was
made available for sale against his will
Lowe quickly recovered thanks to the
apparent indifference of Hollywood and a
willingness to own up to the situation
during the years since he rebounded from
his scandal Lowe has appeared in dozens
of movies including the Cameron Diaz and
Jason Segel movie sex tape which was a
nice meta joke in the form of stunt
casting even more impressive his
television resume spans hundreds of
episodes across dozens of noteworthy
shows including the likes of The West
Wing
Parks and Recreation Californication
Moonbeam City and the grinder thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which actors you think we
should have added to the list
you